انضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك سيد
الياس معنا بدايه ما رايك في مساره تطورات
اذا والمعارك في مدينه
القادمه من الجانبين الاوكراني الروسي
سفيان الوضع في مخموت هو صعب على القوات
الاوكرانيه يبدو ان نهر بخ موتكا والذي
كان عائقا من شرق بخموت اصبح اكثر سهوله
بعد بناء عده جزر عسكريه عده
جسور عسكريه
عبرت بواسطتها القوات الروسيه واصبح
القتال اقرب الى وسط المدينه خاصه بعد
سقوط معمل ازوم وبدانا نرى الالتفاف
الكامل ليس حتى الان يبقى المؤشر قد يكون
هو
الطريق السريع المهم جدا
54 وهو الذي حتى الان يمول بخموت بالذخيره
وبلوجيسيه وحتى بالعديد طيب الكريم في
تصريحاته الاخيره يستبعد السياسه
والدبلوماسيه لحل هذه الازمه برايك كيف
سينعكس ذلك على الارض
الانعكاس سفيان هو استمرار المعركه ما
يريده
هو النصر الشامل والكامل وما يريده الرئيس
الينسكي هو ايضا تحرير الارض الكامل
والامران امران مستعصيان حتى الان الاهداف
كبيره جدا والوسائل المتواضعه ولكن دائما
عند الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات السفيان
ما يعكسه ميازين القوى على الارض
والانجازات هو الذي يحدد كيفيه الجلوس على
الطاوله ومتى الجلوس على الطاوله هذا
الامر ليس موجودا حتى الان دبابات شالنجر
سيد الياس وصلت الى اوكرانيا قادمه من
بريطانيا لكنها تحتاج وقت طويل لتدخل
المعارك هذا ايضا برايك لصالح من سيكون
وكيف سيؤثر على هذه الحرب
كل تاخير باي هجوم عكسي هو لصالح الجيش
الروسي لانه على المدى البعيد اللي يعمل
الوقت لصالحه دبابات تشالنجر وحتى ليوبار
اثنين وحتى كل الاليات المصفحه لا يمكن ان
تقاتل لوحدها هي يجب ان تكون من ضمن
منظومه حتى ان شيء مهم جدا الواقع اليوم
والطقس لا يناسب الدبابات الثقيله اكثر من
60 الى 70 طن من هذه الدبابات بالاضافه
الى الاعتياد عليها التاقلم معها من قبل
المقاتلين يعني المقاتل الدبابه كيف ينسق
مع المدرعه مع المشاه مع الطيران مع
المدفعيه هذه امور من ضمن القتال المشترك
للاسلحه وحتى الان هذا الامر ليس جاهزا
سنكتفي بهذا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
شكرا جزيلا لك